can i ask for your why sage advice to
young people
so advice number one is put down the
phone
uh don't use instagram and and social
media but uh the young people in high
school in college
how to have a career or how to have a
life they can be proud of
yeah i'd be happy to because i i teach a
course at nyu um in the business school
called work wisdom and happiness
and the course is you know it's advice
on how to have a happy you know a
successful career
as a human being but the course has
evolved that it's now about three things
how to get stronger smarter and more
sociable
if you can do those three things then
you will be more successful at work and
in love and friendships and if you are
more successful in work love and
friendships then you will be happier you
will be as happy as you can be in fact
so
the question is how do you become
smarter stronger and happier
and the answer
to all three
is it's a number of things but it's you
have to see yourself as this like
complex adaptive system you've got this
complicated mind that needs a lot of
experience to wire itself up and the
most important part of that experience
is that you don't grow when you are with
your attachment figure you don't grow
when you're safe you have an attachment
figure to make you feel confident to go
out and explore the world in that world
you will face threats you will face fear
and sometimes you'll come running back
but you have to keep doing it because
over time you then develop the strength
to stay out there and to conquer it
that's normal human childhood that's
what we blocked in the 1990s in this
country so
young people have to get themselves the
childhood and this is all the way
through adolescence and young adulthood
they have to get themselves the
experience that older generations are
blocking them from out of fear and that
their phones are blocking them from out
of just you know hijacking almost all
the inputs into their life in almost all
the minutes of their day so
go out there put yourself out in
experiences you are anti-fragile and
you're not going to get strong unless
you actually have setbacks and
criticisms and and fights
um so that's how you get stronger
and then there's an analogy in how you
get smarter which is you have to expose
yourself to other ideas to ideas that
people that criticize you
people that disagree with you
and this is why i co-founded heterodox
academy because we believe that that but
you know faculty need to be in
communities that have political
diversity and viewpoint diversity but so
do students
and it turns out students want this the
surveys show very clearly
gen z has not turned against
viewpoint diversity most of them want it
but they're just afraid of the small
number that will sort of shoot darts at
them if they you know if they say
something wrong so anyway the point is
you're anti-fragile and so you have to
realize that to get stronger you have to
realize to get smarter and then the key
to becoming more sociable is very simple
it's just always looking it through the
other person's point of view don't be so
focused on what you want and what you're
afraid of put yourself in the other
person's shoes what's interesting to
them what do they want
and if you develop the skill of looking
at it from their point of view you'll be
a better conversation partner you'll be
a better life partner
so there's a lot that you can do i mean
i could say you know go read the calling
of the american mind
i could say go read dale carnegie how to
win friends and influence people
um but take charge of your life and your
development because if you don't do it
then uh the the older older protective
generation
and your phone are going to take charge
of you
so on anti-fragility and coddling the
american mind if i may read just a few
lines from chief justice john roberts
which i thought was really beautiful so
it's not just about viewpoint diversity
but it's real struggle absurd unfair
struggle that seems to be formative to
the human mind
he says from time to time in the years
to come i hope you will be treated
unfairly so that you will come to know
the value of justice i hope that you
will suffer betrayal because that will
teach you the importance of loyalty
sorry to say but i hope you will be
lonely from time to time so that you
don't take friends for granted i wish
you bad luck again from time to time so
that you will be conscious of the role
of chance in life and understand that
your success is not completely deserved
and that the failure of others is not
completely deserved either
and when you lose as you will from time
to time i hope every now and then your
opponent will gloat over your failure it
is a way for you to understand the
importance of sportsmanship i hope
you'll be ignored so you know the
importance of listening to others and i
hope you will have just enough pain to
learn compassion whether i wish these
things or not they're going to happen
and whether you benefit from them or not
will depend upon your ability to see the
message in your misfortunes
he read that in a middle school
graduation
yes for his sons his son's middle school
graduation
that's what i was trying to say only
that's much more beautiful yeah and uh i
think your work is really important and
it is beautiful and uh it's bold and
fearless and it's a huge honor to sit
with me i'm a big fan thank you for
spending your valuable time with me
today john thank you so much thanks so
much lex what a pleasure
you